There's one less area of consciousness that we're going to discuss before
moving on to sleeping and dreaming. This is meditation. Now, there's many
different forms of meditation but, in essence meditation is the ability to
become more mindful. Do you remember when we talked about mindfulness a little
while ago in the lesson? Well, by using different meditation techniques, people
who've been able to increase their ability to be more present, in the moment,
and also increase their attention to their thoughts and feelings. Once again,
research has demonstrated that those who score high in mindfulness also report
greater well-being. Reduction in stress and anxiety have also been reported for
those who practice meditation.